[Music]
well most students have spent more than
a year
without in-person learning in the state
of california and in cities like
oakland and san francisco while
teenagers cannot go to math class
they can go to an amusement park it's a
point made by our next guest doctor a
doctor who has been sounding the alarm
for months we've had her on our show
before dr gene noble
she's a professor of emergency medicine
and the director of covid response at uc
san francisco good morning to you doctor
thanks for being on with us
good morning thank you for having me
you're welcome we wanted to have you on
because you tweeted out a picture
and it says there are no hidden
complexities that could possibly explain
this misalignment of social priorities
open schools at gavin newsom and then
you put
you can see on the screen guys if you
want to watch your tv right now you can
see
what you can do and what you can't do
and it says what you can do eat in
restaurants watch movies in theaters go
bowling inside shop in stores work in
offices go to amusement parks attend
houses of worship
work out at gyms indoor pools attend
outdoor live events
what they can't do in the in that state
go to math class english class
science class history class language
class attend pe class outside
attend music dance class in person have
spirit week for social emotional health
why was it important to you dr noble to
to get this message out and put this on
twitter
yeah i think we just really need to
highlight what a preposterous situation
we are now in california you know we
were among the first states to close our
schools because
of covert risk and at that point in time
a year ago
march that made sense we thought that
schools would be super spreaders we have
known for
months that schools are safe places and
we have
opened our economy as coveted rates have
declined precipitously in california
which is great
but we have never had a mandate to
reopen our school so as our economy is
open as amusement
parks and movies and restaurants are all
open now
our schools remain closed there's no
requirement in california
that the schools reopen and the governor
has said back in october his kids go to
private school so they're back in class
he's caught at french laundry why do you
think that he wants to open certain
things but close our schools why are
amusement parks more important than our
schools
well i think he would like schools to
open it's just that he's not willing to
expend the political
capital to mandate that they open he has
given cash incentives to get schools to
open he put teachers in the front of the
line for vaccinations
but that wasn't good enough there are
new demands by the teachers unions
long-standing labor grievances for you
know
subsidized child care and housing
subsidies and shorter work days which
are
potentially all valid labor complaints
but they shouldn't be made on the backs
of our children and
what we need to do since since the
unions have
basically refused to open k-12 schools
is to mandate that they reopen we only
have eight weeks left in this school
year
does it all go back to money they're
going to make money from taxes on these
amusement parks and movie theaters and
things that are open they're not going
to make money on the schools
so why do they want to appease these
unions is it also
going back to money because these unions
the teachers unions give these democrats
money for their campaigns millions for
their campaigns
right well i think our economy is
opening based on our coveted rates we
have a complex tier system that allows
certain sectors of our economy
to open based on daily case rates and
we've seen our covered rates really
decline and so we've opened our economy
but
schools have been excluded from that
while restaurants and bars have been
allowed to open
schools are allowed to open but they are
not required to open
even though article 9 of california
state constitution
mandates the right to unfettered access
to education for kids
it hasn't been it hasn't been done even
though we know it's safe
and our covered rates tell us that we
can do it
and it is i mean there is certainly
money in the politics
the the cta the california teachers
association has more than 300 000
members
they are make political contributions
to to gavin newsom they he does not want
to lose their support
and kids are not voters and kids do not
make political contributions so
there's not the same political pressure
to open our schools
as there has been to open our businesses
dr noble thank you so much for taking
time to come on our show this morning
thanks for covering this important issue